merci de regarder le journal de
l'afrique sur france 24 est heureux de
vous retrouver à la une ces
échauffourées au sein de la commission
électorale kenyane une partie rejette
les résultats de la présidentielle
ce qui donne william ruto gagnant il
devance de peu raïla odinga nous serons
à nairobi
macky sall est à bamako le président de
l'union africaine rencontre à 6 me go
est acquis même la transition au mali
visite qui intervient après
l'inculpation des 49 soldats ivoiriens
par la justice malienne et puis la page
barkan se tourne au mali justement les
derniers militaires français ont quitté
le territoire elles étaient déployés
depuis neuf ans direction le niger notre
équipe a suivi le dernier contingent
une crise politique au kenya est elle en
train de s'ouvrir william ruto a été
déclaré vainqueur de la présidentielle
par la commission électorale six jours
après l élection il gagne d'une courte
tête cinquante cinq pour cent contre
48,9 pour son rival raila odinga annonce
qui divise l'instance parce qu'ils
dénoncent un processus opaque quatre des
sept membres ne reconnaîtrons pas les
résultats le gagnant du scrutin appel au
calme pas de place pour la vengeance
selon lui
le peuple du kenya a gagné parce que
nous avons élevé le niveau politique par
le vrai héros de cette élection c'est la
commission électorale indépendant est
pressée des scènes de chaos qu'a connue
la commission électorales au kenya ce
lundi quatre de ses membres conteste les
résultats qui font de william ruto
l'actuel vice-président le vainqueur de
la présidentielle kenyane face à raila
odinga bastien renouil bonjour vous êtes
le correspondant de france 24 à nairobi
est ce qu'on doit s'attendre à un
recours de la part de raïla odinga
rappelons-le est arrivé donc en deuxième
position et qui se présentait pour la
cinquième fois
bonsoir bien il n'a que deux options
soit accepter la victoire de williams ou
tôt soit aller devant la cour suprême
c'est le seul recours auxquels et
puissent faire face et il y à fort à
parier que ce sera le cas je parlé ce
matin avec des membres du parti à ginola
ou modja de raïla odinga il n'avait pas
encore connaissance du résultat officiel
de cette élection il me disait déjà si
nous perdons nous irons devant la cour
suprême et c'est déjà devant cette cour
suprême que raila odinga avait été en
2017 il doit compilé un dossier avec
toutes les fraudes qu'il aurait recensé
avec toutes les tous les manquements de
la commission électorale un dossier qui
peut être extrêmement longs comme
c'était le cas en 2007 1 de nombreux
volumes avaient été apportées à la cour
suprême est ensuite bien c'est elle qui
tranchera à savoir si cette élection est
valide ou non si elle doit être
réorganisée comme cela avait été le cas
en 2017 c'était une première en afrique
subsaharienne mais le kenya at il les
moyens devraient organiser une élection
la cour suprême peut-elle l'invalidé
rien n'est moins sûr un set une excuse
une élection extrêmement coûteuse l'une
des plus chères au monde le pays souffre
énormément économiquement parlant il
connaît une grave crise économique
les gens ont besoin de pouvoir retourner
travailler ont besoin de relancer
l'économie alors est il possible
d'organiser une nouvelle élection bien
pour l'instant rien n'est moins sûr la
cour suprême devrait trancher raïla
odinga aura sept jours pour déposer son
recours ensuite la cour suprême devrait
l'étudier pendant 14 jours on aurait
donc avoir cette réponse au début du
mois de septembre bastien vous avez
évoqué 2017 il y a cinq ans donc il y
avait ces violences le kenya qui est un
pays malheureusement habitué aux
violences 1 lors de ces élections
tout à fait oui tout le monde a en tête
ce qu'il s'est passé en 2010 est en 2007
en 2007 il y avait eu 1100 morts et près
de 600 mille déplacés après des
violences post électorales en 2017 après
l'annulation du scrutin mais il y avait
aussi eu des violences près de 92 morts
des centaines de blessés alors tout le
monde ici veut éviter de revivre les
mêmes scènes les politiciens en cours
des derniers mois durant la campagne ont
tous appelé à la paix ont tous dit
qu'ils accepteraient le résultat de
cette élection qu'il ne demanderait pas
à leurs supporters de descendre dans la
rue pour manifester comme cela a été le
cas dans le passé alors est-ce que ce
discours va tenir après les scènes qu'on
ait pu vous car durant la journée de ce
lundi à la commission électorale et bien
rien n'est moins sûr les politiciens eux
mêmes qui étaient présents des pontes du
parti de raila odinga en sont venus aux
mains avec la police ont tenté
d'empêcher le président de la commission
électorale d'accéder aux pupitres ont
d'ailleurs rejeté ce pupitre du haut du
podium c'était une véritable scène de
chaos alors comment peuvent-ils dire à
leurs partisans ensuite et bien de ne
pas descendre dans les rues de ne pas
manifester pour l'instant on le sait pas
on ne sait pas ce qu'il va passer au
cours des prochains jours
les soutiens de raila odinga attendant
d'entendre parler raila odinga c'était
notamment le cas aujourd'hui dans le
bidonville de kibera à nairobi c'est
dans les bidonvilles de matériaux lieu
quelques violences en début de soirée
même chose dans la ville de kisumu au
bord du lac victoria un bastion de raïla
odinga trois endroits où les tensions
étaient extrêmement forte par contre
partout ailleurs dans le pays est bien
la situation était au calme avec même
quelques ville qui célébraient la
victoire du oui la moto notamment dans
la vallée du rift l'endroit dont il
vient merci bastien renouil le
correspondant de france 24 à nairobi
accueilli en sauveur en 2013 poussé vers
la sortie par les autorités de
transition en 2022 neuf ans de présence
et les soldats français ont quitté le
territoire malien vous découvrez ici ces
images signées france 24 un retrait acté
en février dernier par emmanuel macron
et qui intervient après des mois de
relations houleuses entre paris et
bamako les militaires ont franchi la
frontière avec le niger là où la france
a décidé de se redéployer là où se
trouve cyril payen pour france 24
c'était un défi humain et logistique
pour le volume et le temps pour
désengager cette dernière emprise cette
dernière base militaire française au
mali c'était un véritable défi qui a eu
à un point de départ à ses déclarations
du président emmanuel macron le
président français le 17 février
dernier donnant six mois à l'armée
française pour se désenclaver pour ré
articulé selon les éléments de langage
qui sont utilisés par l'elysée ou par
l'état-major donc réarticuler la force
barkan cette force anti terroriste anti
djihadistes qui opèrent au sahel vers le
niger voisin où nous sommes maintenant
mais surtout avec en point d'orgue
évidemment quitter le mali où la
situation il faut le dire depuis de
longs mois était devenue intenable tant
pour les militaires français que pour la
diplomatie française aussi puisqu'il y
avait des bisbilles de presque
permanente en tout cas continuer la
lutte anti djihadistes avec de nouveaux
partenaires et le dernier partenaire le
dernier pays alliés en date stable c'est
le niger in y en a il faut le dire pas
beaucoup d'autres maintenant au au sahel
mais il reste quand même une grande
inconnue c'est effectivement cet immense
pays le mali avec ce nord qui est donc
maintenant presque aux mains de
différents affidés du groupe al qaïda ou
du groupe etat islamique avec la montée
en puissance on le sait des mercenaires
du groupe des verts les mercenaires
russes qui sont à la manoeuvre
maintenant au mali après avoir été à la
madoff contre les français en république
centrafricaine et donc beaucoup
d'inquiétudes et c'est un peu aussi en
pour finir ce que nous disaient les
soldats français qui ont passé dont pour
certains beaucoup de missions pu dire de
plusieurs missions depuis 2000 13
opérations serval prédécesseuse de
l'opération markale qui sait qu'il était
très inquiet pour le mali ce mali je
rappelle en 2013 la légion étrangère
avait sauté sur tombouctou pour éviter
justement que bamako de tours
aujourd'hui eh bien il ya une
recrudescence des attaques de violences
menées par ces jihadistes quels qu'ils
soient et des attaques qui maintenant et
ça cet inédit se rapproche
dangereusement de la capitale bamako
donc il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
évidemment sur le plan de la lutte anti
jihadistes dans cette région avec la fin
de cette présence qu'elle soit décrié ou
apprécier cette présence militaire
française au mali le mali où les 49
militaires ivoiriens arrêtés le 10
juillet ont été inculpées motifs
tentative d'atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état bamako les accuse d'être des
mercenaires faux répond abidjan qui
assure que ces soldats étaient en
mission pour les nations unies une
situation évoquée par macky sall le chef
de l'état sénégalais se rend à bamako en
tant que président de l'union africaine
il y rencontre le colonel assimi goïta à
la tête du mali notre correspondante en
côte d'ivoire c'est à dire mandjou suit
de près ce contentieux entre bamako et
abidjan
le président de l'union africaine macky
sall en déplacement ce lundi à bamako
s'est entretenu avec le président de la
transition à 6 me go ita selon le
programme la question des soldats
ivoiriens figure est également à l'ordre
du jour à la sortie de cette rencontre
macky sall a annoncé qu'il fallait
trouver une solution africaine mais
également qu'il note la disponibilité du
mali à poursuivre les communications
pour l'heure aucune réaction officielle
également du côté les autorités
ivoiriennes le chef de l'état major des
armées a quant à lui déclaré je cite
qu'il ne faut pas se fier aux effets
d'annoncé et que les médiations sont
toujours en cours des médiations menées
par le togo est saluée par le président
de l'union africaine du côté des
familles et proches des soldats l'heure
est à la tente contacté par france 24
ils ne veulent pas s'exprimer tant que
l'annoncent n'a pas été reconnue par les
autorités ivoiriennes dimanche une
marche était organisée à abidjan par un
collectif de soutien qui réclame la
libération des soldats ivoiriens macky
sall qui prendra ensuite la direction du
tchad et du gabon saison des pluies
meurtrière au soudan depuis mai ce sont
au moins cinquante deux personnes qui
ont été tuées plus de huit mille
habitations ont été endommagées ou
détruites à bâtiments publics commerces
et terres agricoles ne sont pas épargnés
laurent d'acheter fia
et rang parmi les décombres les
habitants de mackayla ben ne peuvent que
constater les dégâts leur village a été
entièrement détruit par les inondations
qui ont également emporté leur bétail et
leurs récoltes prises au piège par la
montée des eaux ils ne peuvent même pas
se rendre à l'hôpital
il ya des gens qui souffrent de diarrhée
ou d'infections
les il n'y a pas de médicaments le
niveau de l'eau continue de monter et
personne ne fait rien il ya énormément
de moustiques à cause de l'eau stagnante
cela fait trois mois que des pluies
torrentielles s'abattent sur le soudan
provoquant d'importantes inondations qui
ont déjà touché plus de trente huit
mille personnes cette année selon les
nations unies la montée des eaux a
également détruit de nombreuses récoltes
menaçant de provoquer une crise
alimentaire dans un pays déjà en proie à
un effondrement économique
dans l'état d'al jazeera au sud de
khartoum les autorités sanitaires
cherchent à rassurer une population
encore sous le choc
des camions sont en route avec des
tentes de la nourriture et des
médicaments ils doivent arriver demain
matin
le soudan est fréquemment touchée par de
graves inondations durant la saison des
pluies qui s'étend de mai jusqu'à
septembre en 2020 plus de 100 personnes
avaient perdu la vie poussant les
autorités à décréter un état d'urgence
nationale de trois mois
des pluies torrentielles qui tuent aussi
au nigeria depuis juin dans l'état de
jigawa dans nord du pays 50 personnes
sont mortes en raison des inondations
les autorités s'inquiètent pour les
jours à venir de nouvelles
précipitations sont attendues
l'émotion s'est mêlé à la colère au
caire les victimes de l' incendie à
dimanche dans une église copte ont été
inhumés le feu s'est déclenché en pleine
messe bilan 41 morts en cause a priori
un court-circuit et bijoux am and is à
une messe coptes
pour rendre hommage aux victimes de
l'incendié
dimanche soir des centaines d'égyptiens
se sont rassemblés dans une église de la
capitale
pour assister aux funérailles des
disparus
dans ces cercueils sont transportés les
corps des 40 est une victime
sous les cris de douleur des familles
dévastées
l'incendié s'est déclenché en pleine
messe dans une église copte de gisait à
quelques kilomètres du caire selon les
autorités le feu a débuté à cause d'un
court-circuit provoquant la panique des
nombreux fidèles
certaines personnes se sont jetés par
les fenêtres
si vous regardez la voiture défaire
abdullah vous verrez qu'elle est
cabossée parce qu'un homme a sauté par
la fenêtre pour échapper à la mort
cette tragédie a provoqué une vive
émotion dans tout le pays sur twitter le
footballeur international mohamed salah
a fait part de ses condoléances
souhaitant un rétablissement rapide à
tous les blessés
de son côté le président abdel fattah
al-sisi a indiqué avoir donné des
directives pour la reconstruction de
l'église le premier ministre s'est
également rendu au chevet des blessés
dans la mégalopole du caire où des
millions d'égyptiens vivent dans des
bâtiments vétustes les incendies ne sont
pas rares lundi dernier une église a
pris feu à l'est de la capitale mais
sans faire de victime
nous sommes le 15 août jour de
l'assomption fête chrétienne qui célèbre
la montée au ciel de la vierge marie
pour l'occasion au burundi des milliers
de personnes se sont donné rendez vous
sur la colline de mou deraa à 120 km de
bujumbura pour un pèlerinage au
sanctuaire national mariale des fidèles
venus des quatre coins du pays où 80% de
la population est catholique
on se quitte sur ces images signées
france 24 merci de votre fidélité
retrouvez aussi sur france 24 points
comme et nos réseaux sociaux demain à
cette même place meriem à même la halle
restez avec nous prenez soin de vous
[Musique]